esta rotonda de gerson se llama Plaza de
los constructores navales
inesperadamente se ha convertido en un
centro de navegación
se han movilizado todo tipo de
embarcaciones para poner a salvo y
socorrer a los habitantes de las zonas
inundadas
mi casa desaparecido solo se ve el
tejado solo el tejado
las zonas más afectadas por las
inundaciones son también las más
afectadas por los bombardeos rusos Al
otro lado del Río La gente que se marcha
ahora es gente que Había decidido
quedarse a pesar de los riesgos estoy
harta estaba en casa pero ahora todo
Está inundado hasta el segundo piso
Rocky Ven aquí hay muchas mascotas entre
los evacuados y otros animales también
lo encontré sentado en la escalera no
podía dejar que se ahogara Ayer por la
tarde nuestra casa estaba seca pero
cuando nos levantamos esta mañana el
agua tenía un metro de profundidad Así
que esperamos a la evacuación y nos
trajeron en barco
la mayoría de los evacuados dicen que
planean quedarse en los distritos altos
de gersón que no están bajo amenaza
inundación Pero toda la ciudad se verá
afectada por este desastre durante años
Afirma viceministro ucraniano de visita
en la zona
ya los tienen problemas con el
suministro de agua potable estamos
hablando de cientos de miles de
residentes de nuestro país que ya se
están viendo afectados por esto y ahora
con el equipo gubernamental y con los
representantes de las administraciones
militares estamos trabajando para
mitigar los efectos de esta catástrofe
las aguas bajarán en una semana pero
Ucrania tendrá que lidiar con las
secuelas durante años